Oh, how's everybody today doing today? I'm so good, Sean. How are you? Are we actually doing this? Are we talking, are we having a business meeting about when we're doing cold opens? I think we're rolling. We're literally rolling. This is a cold open right now. Okay, because we're not doing another show for another couple of weeks.
噢，大家今天过得怎么样？我很好，肖恩。你呢？我们真的开始了吗？我们在说话吗？我们是在开一个关于什么时候开始即兴开场的商务会议吗？我觉得我们已经开始了。我们真的开始了。这现在就是一个即兴开场。好吧，因为我们在未来几周内不会再录制节目了。
So, anyway, welcome to Smartless. Here it comes. Smart Less Smart Less Oh, wait, what's Suss mean? Any people in your...
所以，不管怎样，欢迎来到 Smartless。它来了。Smart Less Smart Less 哦，等等，“Suspect”是什么意思？你们当中的任何人……
Suspect. That's one of the new ones that kids are saying, right? Not new. God, you're embarrassing yourself. Riz is not new, right? That's a couple years old. Really, really bad.
“Suspect”（可疑）。那是现在孩子们在说的新词之一，对吧？不新。天哪，你真是在丢人现脸。“Riz”不新，对吧？那是好几年前的词了。真的，真的很糟糕。
Is Flexi a new one? Flexi could be good. What, like, what's flexing me? Like, flexible? Yeah. And then what did I hear was, oh, zesty is gay. Is that right?
“Flexi”是一个新词吗？“Flexi”可能不错。“Flexi”是什么意思？像“flexible”（灵活的）一样？是的。然后我听说，哦，“zesty”是“gay”（同性恋）的意思。是这样吗？
Zesty. Oh, sure, I've never heard that. If something is zesty, Will? Have you heard the boys saying that? Sorry. Guys, I've got to keep up. We have to record soon. We're going to start the podcast,
Zesty。哦，当然，我从来没听说过。如果某事很zesty，威尔？你听过小伙子们这么说吗？抱歉。伙计们，我得跟上潮流了。我们马上就要录音了。我们要开始播客了，
and I just want to make sure I've got my... Watching you and hearing you get old in front of me is just astounding. You should have heard the sounds. I made trying to get out of the bed this morning. Super old. Like, you got me going.
我只是想确保我的……看着你、听着你在我面前变老，真是太惊人了。你应该听听我今天早上起床时发出的声音。超级老。就像，你让我破功了。
Like a rogue fart. Just like, ugh, fuck it. All right, back. Boy, you're going to wish you had it said that with our guest. Hey,
就像一个乱飞的屁。就像，呃，操它。好了，回来。天哪，你一会儿会希望你没有在我们的嘉宾面前说这个。嘿，
no, is it respectable. Respectable guest to me? Yes, very respectable. Very, let's start over. She's very classy. God damn it.
不，这很体面。对我来说是体面的嘉宾吗？是的，非常体面。非常，我们重新开始。她非常优雅。该死的。
I'm sorry, surprise, guest. No, it's good. And, J.B., I would say that you started me off on the whole, like, every time you would get out of your chair.
对不起，惊喜，嘉宾。不，这很好。而且，J.B.，我想说的是，你让我开始注意到这种事的，比如，每次你从椅子上站起来的时候。
By the way, not even when you were old. When you were like 33, you'd go, ugh. You've got to make a sound to lock in the core. I know, and somehow I got into that here we go. Yeah, you do, hoit! Well, but you know what Chuggy is, right?
顺便说一句，甚至不是当你老的时候。当你大概33岁的时候，你就会发出“呃”的声音。你得发出声音来收紧核心。我知道，不知怎么的我也染上了这个毛病，开始了。是的，你会的，霍伊特！不过，你知道“Chuggy”是什么意思，对吧？
Chugie is a word that kids used to describe someone or something that's outdated or trying to hard to be trendy or lacking originality. Well, you're reading because you look that up. I just looked it up while you were talking. I was like, well, when you look it up, it's gone. What was the prompt? Hey, what are the kids saying?
“Chugie”是孩子们用来形容某人或某物过时、或者是刻意装时髦、缺乏原创性的词。好吧，你是在照本宣科，因为你在查这个。我只是在你说话的时候查了一下。我想，好吧，当你查完的时候，它已经过去了。提示是什么？嘿，现在孩子们都在说什么？
Absolutely. Really? Absolutely, that's what the prompt was. Sean? Wait, what about how, oh, by the way, the other night at that, this is, what's today? What's today? Wednesday? Tuesday. No, today's Tuesday.
绝对。真的吗？绝对，这就是提示。肖恩？等等，那关于，哦，顺便说一句，前几天在那，这是，今天是几号？今天是几号？星期三？星期二。不，今天是星期二。
Sunday, the center seat in the front row of the play. The girl, this girl just, I could tell she was just a single ticket. Her head was, her head was, cap not. she was an arcolectic hard to get hard to get a date i don't know yeah she kept nodding off and so at the bows i pointed right to her and i just and i mouthed they go you gotta go night you gotta go nine-nigh oh shit sean i did i pointed right to her the whole cast we were laughing on stage and i'm like you gotta go nine-night are you tie-tie oh and what do is she embarrassed or she just kept looking at me
星期天，话剧前排中间座位。那个女孩，这个女孩，我看得出来她自己买了一张单人票。她的头，她的头，一直点。她有点嗜睡，很难搞定，很难约到，我不知道，对吧，她一直在打瞌睡，所以在谢幕的时候，我直接指着她，然后我用口型对她说“你得去睡觉了，你得去睡觉了”。哦，操，肖恩，我真的指着她了，整个剧团都在台上笑，我说“你得去睡觉了”。你是不是累了？噢，她尴尬吗？还是她一直看着我？
She just kept looking at me clapping. Clapping. And she didn't realize I was, I'm looking right at her. But she didn't realize it. Yeah, well, she probably has an issue picking up on social cues and grab proper rest. And definitely proper rest. It's like a very expensive nap. Yeah, yeah.
她就一直看着我鼓掌。鼓掌。她没意识到我在，我正看着她呢。但她没意识到。是的，好吧，她可能不太擅长察言观色，而且明显睡眠不足。绝对是睡眠不足。这就像是一场非常昂贵的午睡。是的，是的。
Did you maybe look at your performance? Believe me. I thought about the whole time. Was she normal or was she chopped? Did she look chopped? What's chopped means? Would you just look up with it? Oh, shit.
你有没有反思一下你的表演？相信我。我一直在想这件事。她是个正常人还是长得很“chop”？她看起来很“chop”吗？“Chopped”是什么意思？你刚才查了吗？哦，操。
Oh, you guys don't have a shot. Oh, God, what is shot? This is a real one. You kind of, kind of, a little busted, a little busted up, little... You're not even reading that. No. So, did that come from Archie or Abel? Listen, I'm, look...
哦，你们这些家伙没听过。哦，天哪，“chopped”是什么？这是一个地道的词。你有点，有点，有点破相了，有点被毁了，有点……你根本没在读那个。没有。所以，那是亚奇（Archie）还是阿贝尔（Abel）说的？听着，我，看……
No, no, no, you're not getting... You're not... So, I'm in with the... Who gave you that? Archie or Abel? Dude, all of our friends. My friends and Archie's friends and Abel's from, because I hang, because we're all young dudes.
不，不，不，你没懂……你没有……所以我是和……谁告诉你的？亚奇还是阿贝尔？老兄，我们所有的朋友。我的朋友、亚奇的朋友和阿贝尔的朋友，因为我跟他们混，因为我们都是年轻的小伙子。
So we're kind of in the same friend group And do you guys say Hey this is a great new flavor of gum You should try it? Or you should hear it is what I usually say Spit it out of your mouth I know I always forget that I've got it going on But you always chew gum
所以我们算是在同一个朋友圈里。你们会说：“嘿，这有一种口香糖的新口味，你应该尝尝！”或者你应该听听，这是我通常会说的话：“把它从你嘴里吐出来。”我知道，我总是忘记我嘴里还嚼着口香糖。但你总是嚼口香糖。
Wait is that the Nicarrette gum Is that what it was on it? Well truth be told I've got some Zinn I've got the little nicotine pouch in Is that another word the kids are using? I'm not one Free shit I like this David Power
等等，那是尼古丁口香糖吗？是那个吗？说实话，我用了一些“Zén”。我塞了一个小的尼古丁小包在里面。那是孩子们用的另一个词吗？我不是。免费的好东西，我喜欢这个大卫能量棒。
bar guys the folks at david um let me give you i'm going to give you in my address uh a little later in the side chat the folks at david shan anything any kind of uh hot fudge or ice cream that you need hoggandaz i love hoggandaz do you i do i can't i can't eat too we like mcconnells we like mcconnells yes we like mcconnells too as well a lot we like them a lot and um obviously Hyundai, Jamsie. Do you want to hear a quick... A quick joke? Laura Piano, Rolex, and NetChance.
伙计们，大卫……的人们，让我给你，我待会儿在私聊里把我的地址给你，大卫的人们，肖恩，任何你需要的热软糖或冰淇淋，哈根达斯，我爱哈根达斯。你爱吗？我爱。我不能吃太多。我们喜欢麦康奈尔（McConnells），我们喜欢麦康奈尔，是的，我们也非常喜欢麦康奈尔，我们非常喜欢他们，显然还有现代（Hyundai）、詹姆西（Jamsie）。你想听一个快讯……一个冷笑话吗？劳罗·皮亚诺（Loro Piana）、劳力士（Rolex）和网趣（NetChance）。
Okay, guys. Wait, do you want to... Wait, a real quick joke. A real quick joke. Ready? So gross. I apologize, everybody. A dwarf psychic just escaped prison.
好了，伙计们。等等，你想……等等，一个非常快的笑话。一个非常快的笑话。准备好了吗？太恶心了。向大家道歉。一个侏儒通灵者刚刚越狱了。
Come on, really? Yeah, there's a small medium at large. There's a small medium at large. I think you work on your reading of that. Okay, I heard a really quick one. This guy's going down the road. There he is. Okay, and he gets to a T in the road,
拜托，真的吗？是的，有一个“small medium at large”（身材矮小的通灵者在逃 / 一个中等身材的人在逃）。有一个身材矮小的通灵者在逃。我觉得你得练习一下这个笑话的读法。好吧，我听到一个非常短的笑话。这家伙在路上开车。他就在那。好吧，他开到了一个丁字路口，
and he doesn't know which way to go. He's kind of lost, and he goes to the right, and all of a sudden his car breaks down. He goes in front, he lifts up the hood. He's trying to figure out what's wrong, and he hears it, it's the alternator, and he looks up, there's a horse there. He goes, what the hell?
他不知道该走哪条路。他有点迷路了，他向右转了，突然他的车抛锚了。他走到前面，掀开引擎盖。他正试图弄清楚哪里出了问题，然后他听到一个声音，说是交流发电机（alternator），他抬起头，那里有一匹马。他说，搞什么鬼？
So he goes down, looks at the car. Again, he can't figure it down. He hears, it's the alternator. He looks back at the horse. He's like, what the... So he tries the alternator, tightens a few screws, starts right up, and he goes.
于是他走回车前，看着车。再次，他找不出原因。他听到声音说，是交流发电机。他回头看着那匹马。他就像，搞什么……于是他检查了交流发电机，拧紧了几颗螺丝，车马上就发动了，他就开走了。
So he's like, oh, man. So he drives to the nearest bar. He gets in the bar, and he says, the barman, he says, give me to a large branding. He just downs it. He says, give me another large branding. He downs it. And the barman goes, oh, ho, ho.
所以他想，哦，天哪。于是他开车到最近的酒吧。他走进酒吧，对酒保说：“给我来一大杯白兰地。”他一口气喝光了。他说：“再给我来一大杯白兰地。”他又一口气喝光了。酒保说：“噢，哦，哦。”
Are you okay, man? He goes, yeah, he goes, I was just driving here. I was lost. I hit a tea in the road. I went to fix my car. And this horse, this talking horse. I decided to go right, and I came upon this horse, and he said, it was the ultimatator.
你还好吗，老兄？他说，是的，他说，我刚刚开车来这儿。我迷路了。我遇到了一个丁字路口。我去修我的车。这匹马，这匹会说话的马。我决定向右走，我碰到了这匹马，它说是交流发电机坏了。
And he goes, oh, man, good thing you didn't go left. He goes, why? Because there's a horse over there that doesn't know anything about cars. come on come on where are we going i know are we going into fucking choke hell you didn't like that because i'm already there that sucked there's a horse over there that doesn't know anything about cars where's the punchline yeah that's it that's fucking terrible we're going to leave that in we're not going to cut it because everyone needs to know that sometimes will clanks it yeah it happens rarely you didn't like you that one i love it i think it's cute stupid all right so our guest our guest our guest
酒保说，哦，天哪，幸好你没往左走。他说，为什么？因为那边有一匹马对汽车一窍不通。拜托，拜托，我们要去哪儿？我知道，我们是要去见鬼的冷笑话地狱吗？你不喜欢那个，因为我已经在那儿了。那个太烂了。那边有一匹马对汽车一窍不通。笑点在哪里？是的，就是这样。这真是太糟糕了。我们要把它留下来，我们不会剪掉它，因为每个人都需要知道，有时候威尔也会砸锅。是的，这偶尔会发生。你不喜欢那个？我喜欢它。我觉得它又可爱又愚蠢。好吧，所以我们的嘉宾，我们的嘉宾，我们的嘉宾……
A couple of pieces of string walk into a bar and they sit down on the stools and the one piece of string says the bartender says give us a couple of beers the bartender says we don't fucking serve string in here
几段绳子走进一家酒吧，在凳子上坐了下来，其中一段绳子对酒保说，酒保给我们来几杯啤酒，酒保说我们这儿不卖妈的绳子。
and the two pieces of string look at each of you come on let's get out of here so they walk outside and one piece of string says the other piece of string quick tie yourself around me he goes what are you doing it just tie yourself around me come on ties itself around and they they hop back in there and they jump up on one stool
然后这两段绳子互相看了一眼，说，来吧，我们离开这儿。于是他们走到外面，其中一段绳子对另一段绳子说，快，把我绑在你身上。那段绳子说，你在干什么？快把我绑在你身上，来吧。它把自己绑好，然后他们蹦蹦跳跳地回到酒吧里，跳上了一张凳子，
and it says give us a couple of beers You go, hey, aren't you those two pieces of string I just kicked out of here? I said, afraid not. Okay? So that's up there with your shit horse joke, but it's slightly better. That's a little...
然后它说，给我们来两杯啤酒。酒保说，嘿，你们不就是刚才被我轰出去的那两段绳子吗？它说，恐怕不是。好吧？所以那个笑话跟你的烂马笑话差不多，但稍微好一点点。那有点……
Good thing you didn't go left. There's a horse over there that doesn't know anything about cars. Oh, Sean's laughing. Sean's just having fun. Let's see of our surprise guests enjoying some of this crap. Imagine a horse.
幸好你没往左走。那边有一匹马对汽车一窍不通。哦，肖恩在笑。肖恩只是在玩得很开心。让我们看看我们的惊喜嘉宾是否在享受这些废话。想象一下一马。
Imagine like, okay, you know, and it, okay. By the way, Franny is eating up Boja. Oh, no, it's Maple. She's eating up BoJack Horseman. Appropriate for her age. But apparently this is a great show. This is an animated show on the Netflix? Oh, my God.
想象一下，好吧，你知道，而且它，好吧。顺便说一句，弗兰妮（Franny）正在狂看《马男波杰克》（BoJack Horseman）。哦，不，那是枫树（Maple）。她正在狂看《马男波杰克》。很适合她的年龄。但显然这是一部很棒的节目。这是一部在Netflix上的动画片吗？哦，天哪。
Is it just getting going? I haven't heard anything about it. I tell you who's been going for a long time is our guest. Oh, nice. She's worked with everybody from, from, we're talking. This is Primo A-List, iconic. She's going to hate me for saying this, but it's true. Actor, she has been, she's worked with everybody from Pacino, De Niro, Nicholson.
它才刚开播吗？我一点也没听说过。我告诉你谁已经出道很久了，那就是我们的嘉宾。哦，太棒了。她和所有人都合作过，从，我们说的是。这是顶级A咖，标志性的。她会因为我说这个而恨我，但这是真的。演员，她和所有人合作过，从阿尔·帕西诺、罗伯特·德尼罗到杰克·尼科尔森。
She's been nominated for three Academy Awards. You know, she's been a queen and catwoman, a dangerous liaison. Yes, it's Michelle Ball. How did you get that? I'm not, how did you get that so fast? To the universe. Michelle Pfeiffer, reveal yourself. Good morning.
她曾三次获得奥斯卡金像奖提名。你知道的，她演过女王、猫女，《危险关系》。是的，她就是米歇尔·法菲尔。你是怎么知道的？我不是，你怎么能猜得这么快？多亏了宇宙。米歇尔·法菲尔，现身吧。早上好。
Oh, she's just late. I'm so mad. She's so bored. Good morning. What a pleasure. Good morning. You got it so fast. I know.
哦，她迟到了。我太生气了。她太无聊了。早上好。真是荣幸。早上好。你猜得太快了。我知道。
There's not that many incredible icons in the world, male or female. You're right there at the top. Hi, Michelle. Hey, hi. How are you? I'm great. How are you? Oh, I'm good.
世界上没有那么多不可思议的偶像，无论男女。你就站在最顶峰。嗨，米歇尔。嘿，嗨。你好吗？我很好。你呢？哦，我很好。
Getting ready to go back to Montana. Oh, for what? For some. For some more Madison. More Madison. So, Michelle, I wanted to start by saying, first of all, I had such a great time. I did a couple days with you on the Madison, which was super fun.
正准备回蒙大拿。哦，去干嘛？去拍点。去拍更多的《黄石之风》（The Madison）。更多的《黄石之风》。所以，米歇尔，我想先说的是，首先，我度过了一段非常美好的时光。我和你在《黄石之风》里拍了几天戏，真的超级有趣。
He came home and raved about you, Michelle. I did. He did. It was, you know, I gushed. Aw. Fun? Wow. It was, it was, it was, yeah.
他回家后对你赞不绝口，米歇尔。我是。他确实说了。你知道的，我一直在夸奖你。啊。有趣？哇。那是，那是，那是，是的。
Are we talking about Will as a scene partner? No, no, Will was great. And he was very, yeah, he was an amazing scene. No, no, love, love, love the director. Love the show, love the actors. It was just. Our scenes were kind of grueling, and we did a lot of takes. We did a lot of takes.
我们在讨论威尔作为对手演员的表现吗？不，不，威尔很棒。而且他非常，是的，他是一个出色的对手。不，不，爱死导演了。爱死这部剧了，爱死演员们了。只是。我们的对手戏有点折磨人，我们拍了很多条。我们拍了很多条。
A lot of angles, and we had, it was heavy, it was just the two of us for about two days, and we were just talking at each other for two days. Was it only two days? Was it like a contentious? Yeah, maybe three. And I was cursing at him. Yeah. Yeah.
有很多角度，而且很沉重，大约两天时间里只有我们俩，我们俩连续两天互相飙台词。只有两天吗？那是充满争议的吗？是的，也许三天。我在对他说脏话。是的。是的。
I'm being having all of us. Thank you. I'm throwing the F-bomb around. I appreciate you not actually using the word on this episode. So Michelle, I went all the way back So in anticipation of having you on the show Which this has been a long time coming And actually we were going to have you a long time ago
我有所有人。谢谢。我到处爆粗口。我很感激你在这个节目里没有真正说那个词。所以，米歇尔，我一路追溯……为了迎接你来到节目中，这件事酝酿很久了。其实我们很久以前就想请你来了。
And then schedule and things That prevented us from having you a long time ago And I've wanted to get into One of the things I love when I look up It says, and I wanted to ask you about this Your first television credit ever Was Fantasy Island, is that true? Oh, no way!
然后因为档期和其他事情，导致我们很久以前没能请到你。我一直想深入了解的一件事，当我查资料时，上面写着，我想问你关于这个，你的第一个电视演出经历是《梦幻岛》（Fantasy Island），对吗？哦，真的吗！
That's cool. What a dream. I had one line. I had one line on Fantasy Island, and I remember the line. What is it? And the line, and the episode was the Island of Lost Women. Sure.
太酷了。真是个梦想。我只有一句台词。我在《梦幻岛》里只有一句台词，我还记得那句台词。是什么？台词是，那集的名字是《失落的女人岛》。当然。
Okay. I was one of the Lost Women, and we were all running around in Togas. Can I guess the line? Pastil. Yes. Here I am. No?
好吧。我是那些失落的女人中的一员，我们都穿着托加长袍跑来跑去。我能猜出台词吗？Pastil（过去式）。是的。我在这儿。不是吗？
No. And it was the closer? They went to credits after that? No. That was the only episode that Sean skipped. Yeah. I was like, boobs, I'm out. It was.
不是。那是剧集的结尾吗？演职员表紧接着就出来了？不是。那是肖恩唯一跳过的一集。是的。当时我的反应是：有胸部，我撤了。就是这样。
It was, it was, who is he, Naomi? Wow. Who is he Naomi? And were you referring to Mr. Rourke? It was, who was it? Herbe Pellichess? I can't remember who was. And there were no men, I mean, the premises, there were no men on the island.
那是，那是，他是谁，娜奥米？哇。他是谁，娜奥米？你是在指罗克先生（Mr. Rourke）吗？那是谁？埃尔维·皮尔切斯（Hervé Villechaize）？我不记得那是谁了。而且没有男人，我的意思是，前提是岛上没有男人。
And so we were all, we were. They were all lusting over this one man. Who, oh, but you don't remember who that, and that was a guest guest, guest. I don't. You could, well, did you do your homework. Did you look at the credits? No, sorry, didn't say who you're sure.
所以我们都在。她们都渴望着这同一个男人。是谁，哦，但是你不记得那是谁了，那是一个客串演员，客串。我不记得了。你可以，好吧，你做功课了吗？你看过演员表吗？没有，抱歉，没说你是谁。
Not on Wickey. I mean, it did say it. Didn't they do a lot of that? Wasn't that done like on a back lot at one of the studios? It was huge, universal background maybe? I'm guessing it was universal, but it could have been Warner Brothers. You didn't, you didn't, like you didn't fly to Hawaii. or something, right?
不在维基百科上。我是说，上面确实写了。他们不是在那里拍了很多戏吗？那是不是在其中一个片场的内景场地拍的？也许是巨大的环球影城背景？我猜是环球影城，但也有可能是华纳兄弟。你没有，你没有，就像你没有飞去夏威夷之类的地方，对吧？
No, yeah, right. No, they flew me to Hawaii. No. Yeah, no. No, but I do remember how exciting it was, showed up for work, and there was, you know,
不，是的，对吧。没有，他们把我飞去了夏威夷。没有。是的，没有。不，但我确实记得那是多么令人兴奋，去片场上班，然后有，你知道的，
Honeywagon, all the rooms there. You were at a Honeywagon, for sure, with one line. For sure. You're lucky to even... Can you just tell Tracy real quick, Sean's going to his sister? Yeah, a HoneyWagon is, it's a trailer
化妆车，那里的所有房间。你绝对待过化妆车，只有一句台词。绝对待过。你甚至很幸运能……你能跟特雷西快速说一下吗，肖恩要去他姐姐那？对，化妆车是一个拖车，
where you, as an actor, you hang out while they're working on... But it's divided... And it's divided up into... small rooms. Very small rooms and they put you in there like a veal. Yes. It's just enough room to turn.
作为演员，当他们工作时你在里面消磨时间……但它是分隔开的……它被分割成……很小的房间。非常小的房间，他们把你像小牛肉一样塞进去。是的。只有刚好能转身的空间。
You can go to the restroom, brush your teeth and change your shoes all sitting on one seat. What more does one need? Nothing. It's very efficient. But I was very excited because I looked up and there was my name and a star. Yeah. They knew. Like you made it.
你坐在同一个座位上就能上厕所、刷牙和换鞋。一个人还需要什么呢？什么都不需要。非常高效。但我非常兴奋，因为我抬头一看，上面有我的名字和一颗星星。是的。他们知道的。就像你成功了一样。
They knew. Yeah. Yeah. So tell me like, tell me what. By the way, it's so nice to see. I think we met a long. long, long time ago, but she doesn't remember. Just in passing, no, she doesn't remember.
他们知道的。是的。是的。所以告诉我，告诉我……顺便说一句，见到你真高兴。我想我们很久、很久、很久以前见过面，但她不记得了。只是擦肩而过，不，她不记得了。
But this is the first time I've gotten to talk to you, so it's such a pleasure. And what was that like when you, the first time when you, so before Fantasy Island had you been pursuing it? How did you fall into it? Like, how did you get that first job? I had taken theater in high school to avoid having to take an English class.
但这是我第一次有机会跟你说话，所以真是荣幸。当你第一次，在《梦幻岛》之前，你一直在追求演艺事业吗？你是怎么踏入这一行的？你是怎么得到第一份工作的？我在高中时选修了戏剧课，为了避免上英语课。
I think it was grammar that I was avoiding. And so I sort of fell into it. and I thought all the theater people were just kind of, you know, geeky. Yeah, yeah, for sure they are. And anyway, I just, I mean, I just fit right in. And I just sort of fell in love with it. And then anyway, graduated. I didn't think I would ever in my wildest dreams to become an actor.
我想我当时是在逃避语法课。所以我算是误打误撞进去了。我觉得所有戏剧界的人都挺，你知道的，书呆子气的。对，对，他们绝对是的。不管怎样，我就是，我的意思是，我简直如鱼得水。我差不多就爱上了它。然后不管怎样，毕业了。我做梦也没想到自己会成为一名演员。
I just wasn't a part of that. I'd never met an actor. I'd never met a famous person. And your family was, there was no sort of acting connection in your family. Nothing. Nothing. Nothing. In fact, my dad was not thrilled at the notion of me. Where were you? Where did you grow up? An Orange County, not that far away from L.A.
我根本不是那个圈子的人。我从来没见过演员。我从来没见过名人。你的家庭，你的家族里没有任何与表演相关的背景。完全没有。完全没有。事实上，我爸爸对我的这个想法一点也不兴奋。你是在哪儿长大的？你在哪儿长大的？在橙县（Orange County），离洛杉矶不远。
Anyway, so I was working at Vaughn's supermarket. I love it. Yeah. Check out? Check out. Yeah. And it wasn't a very good checker. I could never balance my cash register. Yeah, and those are the days where you had to type in the price. Yeah. And you didn't just scan stuff.
不管怎样，我当时在沃恩超市（Vaughn's supermarket）工作。太棒了。收银员？收银员。是的。而且我不是个好收银员。我从来平不了账。是的，那是必须手动输入价格的年代。是的，你不能只是扫描商品。
Those were the days, right, way back then. Get some skills. Now, did you not go to college and like study up on some, you know, tangible something you could really rely on like a real? Or were you just like, I'm all in. And if this doesn't work, I'm going back to slinging melons. I had started a trade school. I was doing court reporting. Oh, really?
那是些好日子，对吧，很久以前。学点技能。现在，你没有去上大学，然后学习一些切实可行、可以真正依靠的东西，比如一门真正的……或者你只是觉得，我全押了？如果这行不通，我就回去卖甜瓜。我上过一所职业学校。我在学法庭速记。哦，真的吗？
Wow. And that made me crazy in the head because you have to sort of, like, learn a whole new language. Yeah. And then you have to type it out like this. What's the conographer? Synographer. Snographer.
哇。那让我头脑发狂，因为你得，比如说，学习一门全新的语言。是的。然后你得像这样把它打出来。什么是速记员？速记员。速记员。
Wait, so you know how to do that? Not anymore. But what would happen was after about a year of studying that, every time I would talk to people, my hands would start going like this. Really? Like you were typing? And I'm transcribing. Every single thing.
等等，所以你知道怎么做？现在不了。但会发生的情况是，学了一年之后，每次我跟别人说话，我的手就会开始这样动。真的吗？就像你在打字一样？我在转录。每一分每一秒。
And it's not a quirky keyboard, is it? No, it's like a different kind of keyboard. No, it's a totally different, you have to learn a completely, different language. It's a fully different language. Did it help you memorize dialogue going forward? No. I mean, maybe. Good question, though, Will.
那不是个奇怪的键盘，对吧？不，那是一种不同类型的键盘。不，完全不同，你必须学习一种完全不同的语言。是一门完全不同的语言。它对你以后记住台词有帮助吗？没有。我是说，也许吧。不过是个好问题，威尔。
Thanks. I was just thinking it would be funny. I wonder if you ever lost a job. You know, you said you took acting because you didn't want to do this grammar class. And I wonder if you ever lost a job. They were like, we really wanted to hire her, but her grammar was terrible.
谢谢。我只是觉得这会很搞笑。我想知道你有没有丢过工作。你知道的，你说你选修表演是因为你不想上语法课。我在想你有没有因为这个丢过工作。他们说：“我们真的很想雇她，但她的语法太糟糕了。”
Yeah. She doesn't speak good. I've been, since you popped on our little screen here today to talk, it's really hard for me to hold. I have, you know, Greece too is one of my favorite movies of all time. Really? And I'm sure you get it all the time. And I'm so sorry,
对。她话说不好。自从你今天出现在我们的小屏幕上聊天以来，我真的很难克制自己。你知道的，《油脂2》（Grease 2）是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。真的吗？我确信你经常听到别人这么说。我很抱歉，
but me and my sister watched it a thousand times. I know every word, every song. My sister and I. Who else is bad? Michelle was about to correct him. I'm just kidding. Anyway, I just, I just, it was a huge part of my childhood, Greece, too. And we would just watch it over and over and over again.
但我跟我姐姐看了它上千遍。我记得每一个字，每一首歌。我和我姐姐。还有谁不好？米歇尔正要纠正他。我开玩笑呢。不管怎样，我只是，我只是，它是我的童年极其重要的一部分，《油脂2》。我们就这样一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地看。
I know every line of dialogue and every line of dialogue and everywhere. So it's really cool that you are part of my... What's your favorite part in the film? Isn't that cool? I think one of my favorite parts of the film is a girl for all seasons, because it's so ridiculous.
我记得每一句台词，每一句对话，每一个字。所以你成为我的……真是太酷了。你在电影里最喜欢的片段是什么？不是很酷吗？我想我在电影中最喜欢的片段是“一个适合所有季节的女孩”（A Girl for All Seasons），因为它太荒谬了。
I'll be your girl for all seasons. John, I'm dressed as a Christmas tree. Absolutely, absolutely. And how many... Sean, how many times have you reenacted Cool Rider on a ladder? A thousand times. Okay. I need to see...
我会成为你所有季节的女孩。肖恩，我打扮得像棵圣诞树。绝对，绝对。还有多少……肖恩，你在梯子上重现过多少次《酷骑手》（Cool Rider）？一千次。好吧，我得看看……
You know, there's somebody online who did that, actually, and I reposted it. Oh, really? There's a guy who reenacts all. every scene. Do you get that a lot in your life that people just know? It's like a cult, like, classic.
你知道的，网上有人真的做过那个，而且我转发了。哦，真的吗？有个家伙重现了所有的场景。你在生活中经常遇到这种情况吗，人们就是知道？这就像是一个邪典经典。
Like, people... Yeah, yeah. Is that the thing people do the most from Greece to, like, going outlandish and recreating stuff? You mean... Like, do people come up and quote lines or, like, is that the one that people go,
就像，人们……是的，是的。人们对《油脂2》做的事情最多的是这个吗，比如搞得很离谱然后重新演绎？你是说……就像人们走过来背台词，或者那是人们会说的那部剧吗，
oh my God, I love, like, Sean, like sort of fan going out? Yeah, yeah. That is... That's a big one. And I guess probably... Well, and then you've got all the people quoting Scarface, which is crazy. But mostly they're quoting Tony Montana, not really me.
哦，天哪，我喜欢，就像肖恩那样有点狂热的粉丝？是的，是的。那是……那是一个很大的点。我想大概……好吧，然后你还有所有那些引用《疤面煞星》（Scarface）的人，这太疯狂了。但他们大多引用的是托尼·蒙塔纳（Tony Montana），而不是我。
And Fabious Baker Boys. Oh, yeah. What about that, Sean? Have you sung on top of a piano? Of course. I pick a nap on top of a piano. Oh, my God. I remember when that movie came out.
还有《一曲难忘》（The Fabulous Baker Boys）。哦，是的。那个呢，肖恩？你在钢琴顶上唱过歌吗？当然。我在钢琴顶上小睡过。哦，天哪。我记得那部电影上映的时候。
I love those guys, too, is so much. I love Bo and Jeff Bridges. What great dudes. And, I mean, just the best. That movie was so good, Michelle. The best. Right? And we will be right back.
我也非常喜欢那些家伙，我太喜欢了。我爱博（Beau）和杰夫·布里吉斯（Jeff Bridges）。多棒的伙计们啊。我的意思是，简直是最好的。那部电影太棒了，米歇尔。最棒的。对吧？我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. Michelle, like you, you could go on and on and on with all of the incredible things that you have done. Do you take the time ever privately to kind of give yourself a little pat on the back for the longevity, the amount of time you have spent in a relevant position in an industry that's famous for, or it's unpredictability, and it's so sort of fickle. And, like, you have been incredibly well-respected and sought after for probably five times longer than your average actor or actress.
现在回到节目中。米歇尔，就像你一样，你可以没完没了地列举你所做过的所有不可思议的事情。你有没有在私底下花时间好好夸奖一下自己，为了你的长青，为了你在这个以不可预测性和善变著称的行业里保持相关地位的时间长度？而且，你受到的尊重和追捧，可能比普通男女演员平均时间长五倍。
It's just, it's admirable. Don't you find it, I find it, first I'll know. I don't. I'm always surprised, actually, to hear people say that. But I also find today it's really hard to feel relevant in any way because it does feel like, you know. Everybody's famous. Everybody's sort of getting their 15 minutes.
这简直令人钦佩。你不觉得吗？我发现，首先，我知道。我不觉得。事实上，听到别人这么说，我总是很惊讶。但我也发现，现在要在任何方面都感到自己有相关性真的很困难，因为感觉上，你知道的。每个人都成了名人。每个人都在经历他们的15分钟成名时间。
And you kind of, so it doesn't, I don't know, it doesn't feel that way, honestly. Right, but it turns out, it seems like there's, well, there's certainly enough room for you, right? You are still doing that which you want at the pace that you want, it seems, from the outside. I mean, you've got three, you've got the Madison, you've got your show on your Apple TV, you've got a movie coming out as well, right, for Amazon? Like, you're busy. Well, yeah, I'm a little too busy.
然后你会觉得，所以，我不知道，老实说并没有那种感觉。好吧，但事实证明，似乎……好吧，对你来说当然有足够的空间，对吧？从外表看，你依然在按你想要的节奏做你想做的事。我的意思是，你有三部作品，你有《黄石之风》，你有你在Apple TV上的剧，你还有一部即将上映的电影，对吧，为亚马逊拍的？你看上去很忙。好吧，是的，我确实有点太忙了。
I didn't really plan to. Look, I'm so grateful. I'm so grateful because I love acting. I've never lost. In fact, I probably enjoy it more now than I ever have because... Really? Yeah, I'm sort of more relaxed with it. I actually didn't, you know, when I had all of this work,
我其实并没有计划这样。看，我很感激。我非常感激，因为我热爱表演。我从未失去过。事实上，我现在可能比以往任何时候都更享受它，因为……真的吗？是的，我对它更放松了。我其实并没有，你知道的，当我有了所有这些工作，
plus I have a fragrance company that I founded like seven years ago. And so, you know, at a time when I wasn't working all this much. So I don't really have time to be thinking about anything but the task at hand. But when I had all these acting jobs coming up, I thought, okay, okay. How are you going to manage this and have a life? Because that hasn't always been easy for me. I'm an all-or-nothing kind of girl. And when I approach things,
再加上我大约七年前创立了一个香水公司。所以，你知道的，在一个我没有那么多工作的时期。所以我真的没有时间去考虑手头任务以外的事情。但当我所有的表演工作接踵而至时，我想，好吧，好吧。你将如何兼顾这一切并拥有生活？因为那对我来说并不总是容易的。我是个要么全盘接受、要么彻底放弃的女孩。当我接近事物时，
and I always like taking on challenges, and then I get into it, and it's sort of sink or swim. And for whatever reason, I kind of feed on that. maybe not so healthy, I don't know. But so my approach has been, this gets back to why am I enjoying it more now than ever, is I don't have time to, nor the desire to go that deep for that long and not be present.
我总是喜欢接受挑战，然后我深入其中，这有点像生死存亡。不管出于什么原因，我有点靠这个维系。也许不太健康，我不知道。所以我的方法一直是——这回到了为什么我现在比以往任何时候都更享受它——我没有时间，也没有欲望去那么深刻地投入那么长时间却无法保持当下。
You know, I really, I realize, you know, I have a finite amount of time left. and um i might i might announce on this show that i became a grandmother last year excellent well done i've been very quiet about it and it is the greatest right it's heaven it's it's it's it's it's heaven it's ridiculous it's um congratulations by the way that's pretty And if I had known that I was going to be a grandmother, I wouldn't have taken on so much work. But I've enjoyed everything and I'm really grateful. I mean, I've loved each of these projects.
你知道的，我真的，我意识到，你知道的，我剩下的时间有限。而且……我可能会在这个节目中宣布，我去年当祖母了。太棒了，干得好。我对此一直很低调，这是最棒的感觉，对吧？那是天堂，那是天堂，那是天堂，太荒谬了。恭喜你，顺便说一句，那真是……如果我知道我要当祖母了，我就不会接那么多工作了。但我享受每一件事，我真的很感激。我的意思是，我爱极了每一个项目。
And so the weird thing is that sort of giving up that angst about the process has freed me up. And I feel in some ways has made me better. You mean the angst about the process of. actually studying to play that character, doing the research, yada, yada. Oh, I have to know this, and I have to... Right, and no longer. You know, and I have to free a...
所以奇怪的事情是，抛弃对这个过程的焦虑让我解脱了。我觉得在某些方面这让我变得更好了。你是说对这个过程的焦虑——实际上是研究如何扮演那个角色，做调查，诸如此类。哦，我必须知道这个，我必须……对，不再这样了。你知道的，我必须释放一个……
I have to personalize this, and I have to, you know... And yes, yes, there's a certain amount of that you have to do, and that's important. Yeah. But then, you know, and then you start, though, but there's something amazing for me about showing up and it's about discovery. Yes, and also I bet you bring more of...
我必须把这个个性化，我必须，你知道的……是的，是的，你必须做一定数量的那种工作，那很重要。是的。但然后，你知道的，然后你开始，不过，对我来说，有一种奇妙的事情是现身，一切都是关于探索。是的，而且我敢打赌，你带来了更多的……
yourself now than ever before. Is that correct? Yes, I think you might be right. Yeah, that's a first. For better or worse, Sean. For better or worse, Sean. Yeah, but I mean like it makes you fearless, more fearless. Yeah, I'll bet Michelle, you would say for better, right?
现在的你比以往任何时候都多。对吗？是的，我想你是对的。是的，这还是第一次。不管好坏，肖恩。不管好坏，肖恩。是的，但我的意思是这让你无所畏惧，更加无畏。是的，我敢打赌，米歇尔，你会说这是好事，对吧？
Because if we're doing things correctly, which it sounds like you are, you become a better and better version of yourself as you get older. and as an actor sort of by a consequence you're bringing more interesting abilities to pretending to be other people so I'll bet your work has gotten even better right? I mean do you watch your own stuff
因为如果我们把事情做得对，听起来你确实在这样做，随着你年龄的增长，你会成为一个越来越好的自己。作为一个演员，结果就是你会把更有趣的能力带给假装成其他人这件事上，所以我敢打赌你的工作变得更好了，对吧？我的意思是，你看自己的作品吗？
I mean can you allow yourself to watch yourself and go that's a little bit better than what I did five years ago or 10 years ago or it's hard for me to like my work and watch it and that's the other thing is I used to see every days daily, the work before. Had to see what I was doing, had to see where I was at,
我的意思是，你能允许自己看自己的作品，然后说“这比我五年前或十年前做的好一点”吗？对我来说，喜欢自己的作品并观看它是很难的，还有一点就是，我过去常常看每一天的样片，看之前的作品。必须看看我在做什么，必须看看我的状态如何，
had to know, do I need to make a shift, do I need to? Yeah. And I don't. I just don't anymore. What happened? When did that change? It gradually started shifting. Actually, that was a while ago because I was just torturing myself.
必须知道，我需要做出调整吗？我需要吗？是的。而我现在不这样了。我不再这样了。发生了什么？什么时候开始改变的？它逐渐开始转变。事实上，那是很久以前的事了，因为我当时简直是在折磨自己。
So you didn't like what you were seeing or you got more confident in, You know what? I keep checking, but it's fine. Or were you doing it to punish yourself on a certain level? Do you think? I'm just very, I'm just super critical. Yeah.
所以你不喜欢你所看到的，或者你变得更自信了，你知道吗？我一直在检查，但没关系。或者你在某种程度上这样做是为了惩罚自己？你觉得呢？我只是非常，我只是超级苛刻。是的。
Okay. So then you left it and you're like, I'm just going to be mean to myself so I don't even want to look. No, mean to my. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Because I know, no matter what I see, I'm going to find the negative.
好吧。所以然后你放弃了，你想着：我只是要对自已刻薄一点，所以我甚至不想看了。不，对自已……是的。是的。是的。是的。因为我知道，无论我看到什么，我都会找出负面的东西。
I'm going to find the negative. And I'm going to find the negative. day and do it the best way I know how anyway I'm always going to give 110 percent I'm not going to well I guess the danger of looking at it and caring and is if you start watching that and you start relying on that you you run the risk of dragging that and your opinion of that to the next day and it affects what you do not in the way that's constructive but potentially going oh I want to avoid this this this and this, and now you're in some weird loop, you know what I mean?
我总会找出负面的东西。我总是会尽我所能以最好的方式去过好每一天。我总是会付出百分之百的努力。我不会……好吧，我想看它并在乎它的危险在于，如果你开始看那个，并开始依赖那个，你就会冒着把那个以及你对它的看法拖到第二天的风险，它会影响你的所作所为，不是以一种建设性的方式，而是潜在地让你觉得“哦，我想避免这个、这个、这个和这个”，然后你就陷入了某种奇怪的循环，你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, and the other thing about it, too, is that then you become, rather than something happening spontaneously because you're just going with your instincts and you're in the moment, you start copying yourself. Oh, that was really good. That was a really good moment. Ah, and you try to regenerate it. And then you're not in the moment anymore, which is what made it so good. And also what could have made it so bad.
是的，另一件事是，这样一来，你就不是在根据直觉顺其自然、身处当下而自发地发生某些事情，而是在开始模仿自己。哦，那真的很棒。那是一个非常好的时刻。啊，然后你试图去重现它。然后你就不再处于当下了，而这正是让它变得如此美好的原因。这也是可能让它变得如此糟糕的原因。
But, you know, that thing about like a painter, like when you paint, sometimes you go, okay, but those moments where you missed led to the good moment. And it's like a painter, it's the same thing because I paint and you have your painting and you have an idea and you start painting and then you make a mistake. And then you have to go about how am I going to fix this? Well, you don't have a plan how to fix it
但是，你知道，就像一个画家，当你画画时，有时你会想：好吧，但那些你失误的时刻通向了美好的时刻。这就像一个画家，是一样的，因为我画画，你有了你的画，你有一个想法，你开始画，然后你犯了个错误。然后你必须考虑我该如何修复这个。好吧，你没有计划如何修复它，
because you didn't plan on making a mistake. So now you have to just figure that out and it ultimately typically will end up being the favorite part of your painting. And so I think when you're creating, I think that's all part of the process. And so just... I love that you paint.
因为你没打算犯错。所以现在你必须弄清楚这一点，最终它通常会成为你这幅画里最喜欢的部分。所以我认为当你在创作时，我认为这都是整个过程的一部分。所以只是……我喜欢你画画。
Of course you're painting. You're going to be cooler. Everything you say is just the one thing's cooler than the next. Wait, Michelle, you work with... By the way, I have a fragrance called Dave. Dave. Come on. Dave.
你当然会画画。你总是那么酷。你说的每一句话都是一件比一件酷。等等，米歇尔，你和……顺便说一句，我有一款名为“Dave”的香水。Dave。拜托。Dave。
Well, maybe Dave should meet the David Palibar. Maybe they should be friends. The power bar out of here, we're talking about Michelle's fragrance. What is wrong with you? I do think before we move on, Sean, I really think you should track down the gal in the front row and ask her how you can fix your mistake.
好吧，也许Dave应该去见见David能量棒。也许他们应该成为朋友。把能量棒拿开，我们在谈论米歇尔的香水。你到底怎么了？在往下进行之前，肖恩，我真的认为你应该去把前排的那位女士找出来，问问她你该如何弥补你的错误。
You know? Okay, straighten out your performance and stop putting people to bed. I totally will do that. I totally will do that. Wait, Sean, can't you get in serious trouble? Like, if you're on the stage and you break and you like start talking to the audience,
你知道吗？好吧，调整你的表演，别再把人哄睡着了。我完全会这么做。我完全会这么做。等等，肖恩，你难道不会惹上大麻烦吗？比如，如果你在台上出戏，然后开始跟观众说话，
Isn't that sort of like a time? He hit fuck it 10 years ago, don't worry. He's been trying to get fired off an Oscar for it. No, no, I noticed her dozing off for the first hour of the play while I'm in it. And then I waited until the end of the, at the boughs, when everybody's clapping. Oh, it wasn't in the middle of your performance.
这难道不算是一种……他10年前就已经无所谓了，别担心。他一直试图因此被奥斯卡解雇呢。不，不，我注意到她在戏剧的前一个小时里一直在打瞌睡，而我还在演。然后我一直等到结束时，在谢幕时，当大家都在鼓掌的时候。哦，不是在你的表演进行到中间的时候。
No, no, no, no. Was it the applause that woke her up? I think it was the applause that woke her up. That's funny. That's funny. When I come next week, I'm going to bring. a pillow is it sounds like that's what i need to do wait uh michelle i was going to ask you you know you've worked with so many great directors over the years i mean some just some of the all-time
不，不，不，不。是掌声把她吵醒的吗？我想是掌声把她吵醒的。这太好笑了。这太好笑了。我下周来的时候要带个枕头，听起来这正是我需要做的。等等，米歇尔，我正想问你，你知道的，这些年来你和那么多伟大的导演合作过，我的意思是，有些简直是历代最伟大的，
grades and were you was that a time and was there a time when you were just director-driven or has that shifted what do you what do you look for when you're when you're deciding now director's super important i mean initially you just want a job and and and then once you start getting work and then it's like obviously just choosing the best of what is put in front of you and hopefully you're able to get, you know, pickier and pickier as you go along.
那是一个时期吗？有没有那么一段时间，你完全是由导演驱动的？或者这种情况已经改变了？当你现在做决定时，你看重什么？导演超级重要。我的意思是，最初你只是想找份工作，然后当你开始有工作时，很显然就是挑选摆在你面前最好的东西，希望随着你资历加深，你能变得越来越挑剔。
And then, yeah, when you're in a position where you have that kind of choice, it's a tough one, like, is it script? Is it director? I mean, a lot of, I've seen really talented directors make, I would not maybe masterpieces, but great films. out of not so great scripts.
然后，是的，当你处于拥有那种选择权的地位时，这是一个艰难的抉择，比如，是剧本吗？是导演吗？我的意思是，我看过很多真正有才华的导演，他们把并不那么伟大的剧本拍成了——也许不是杰作——但也是伟大的电影。
Yeah. And then I've seen maybe in the wrong hands a really great script. Just. Yeah. So. In some ways, I think I would, if I had to choose, I would say director. And then I think the part is, you know, does it kind of just speak to you? I mean, for me, I can hear it.
是的。我也见过在错误的人手中，一个真正伟大的剧本。只是……是的。所以在某些方面，如果要我选，我会说导演。然后我认为角色是，你知道的，它是否能触动你？对我来说，我能听到它。
I can hear it. I can see it. I'm very visual. Does it matter if it's the lead or 7, 6, 7, 8, 9? down the call sheet. If it's a direct-of-year-old... Six, seven, eight, nine. Well, listen, now you're getting in a honey-wagon territory.
我能听到它。我能看到它。我非常注重视觉。是主角还是演职员表上的第六、第七、第八、第九位重要吗？如果是一个伟大的导演……第六、第七、第八、第九。好吧，听着，现在你进入化妆车领域了。
You know, I recently have, especially like, you know, working on a Marvel movie or something, and you have a tent on the stage, and you're in a costume, you can't pee, you know, you can't go to the bathroom in unless you... And it's... You know, I've had to beg for a honey wagon size room. I'm like just, I just need a place to go sit
你知道的，我最近，特别是在拍漫威电影之类的作品时，你在片场搭个帐篷，你穿着戏服，你不能撒尿，你知道，除非你……而且……你知道的，我不得不乞求一个化妆车大小的房间。我想我只是需要一个可以去坐着的地方。
and work on my stuff that has a little tiny toilet you know? Right, right, right. And couldn't have been half years so. Right, right, right. Let me ask you something, this might be like we don't have to go there if you don't want to, but having your breadth
然后去弄我的那个带有一点点小马桶的东西，你知道吗？对，对，对。而且不可能是一年半什么的。对，对，对。我问你个事，这可能……如果你不想聊的话，我们也可以不谈，但鉴于你那浩瀚
of work over literally decades like amazing work one after another, have you seen a change for the better in either roles for women from the beginning of a career to now or how being a woman in the business has changed at all have you experienced any of that yourself
的作品，真的是几十年如一日一部接一部的神作，你有没有发现，从你的职业生涯开始到现在，女性的角色在往好的方向改变？或者说，这个行业里作为女性的现状有没有什么改变？你自己经历过这些吗？
or have you just been like no it's been I've just been sailing along before you even answer that here's one thing that I just find incredibly impressive about you and you don't have a lot of company in this you have been able to have your talent as an actor overshine your extraordinary beauty from day one, which extends into, you know, I would imagine,
还是说你觉得“没有啦，我一直都顺风顺水”？在你回答之前，我发现你身上有一点特别让人佩服，而且这方面你几乎没有竞争对手——你从第一天起，就能让你的演员天赋盖过你那非凡的美丽，这自然延伸到了……
so many interesting roles now as one gets older, the roles get better, and since you never traded just on your looks, there's no end of relevance there. Like, it was always about the talent with you. That's right. That was so delicately walked through and so impressive. I'm in deep sweat.
现在有这么多有趣的角色，随着人变老，角色变得越来越好，而且因为你从来不只靠颜值，所以你的热度永远不会消退。对你来说，焦点始终在于天赋。没错。这个问题切入得太巧妙了，太令人佩服了。我都开始冒冷汗了。
You're so close to trouble on either side. He is teetering. I'm like he is so teetering on the edge of this. Did I make it? Did I shut up in time? So impressed. Wow. I was just more to the point. It was beautiful. How does it feel being an aging actress in Hollywood?
两边你都差点惹上麻烦。他摇摇欲坠。我就觉得他在这边缘摇摇欲坠。我过关了吗？我及时闭嘴了吗？太佩服了。哇。我只是直奔主题。这太美妙了。作为一个日渐老去的了好莱坞女演员，你感觉如何？
Why don't you just say it, Sean? No. No. Michelle, I was going to say that I think that you're even cooler than you are, Which is saying a lot. That is the truth. Am I cool? I always feel like. I'm such a nerd.
肖恩，你为什么不直接说出来呢？不。不。米歇尔，我是想说，我觉得你比你自己以为的还要酷，这已经很了不起了。真的。我很酷吗？我总觉得自己。我就是个书呆子。
Very, very cool. Like, pick your scandal in the news, in the news over the last 40 years about this business that we're all in. And a lot of the times it has to do, not all the time, but a lot of it has time to do with women and how they've been mistreated. It's so bad. And so I didn't know if you could speak to that. Shana, you try to get headlines for us? No. Oh, no.
非常非常酷。比如，随便挑一个过去40年里我们这个圈子里的丑闻新闻，很多时候——虽然不是全部，但很多时候——都跟女性以及她们如何被虐待有关。太糟糕了。所以我不知道你能不能谈谈这个。肖恩，你想给我们弄个大新闻吗？不。哦，不。
Did he get out of the dark water and get it? The shallow, turquoise. Yeah, we just got out of the deep end, Sean. Now, there you go, diving back in. Wow, that was a lot to unpack, guys. So where do you want me to start? This is your time. How are the roles seem to you?
他这是从深水区游出来了，还是在……浅浅的土耳其蓝水里？对，我们刚从深水区上来，肖恩。现在好了，你又一头扎回去了。哇，大家要消化的信息量真大。你想让我从哪儿开始？这是你的主场。你觉得现在的角色怎么样？
Better or worse? Well, you know what, they're better, but they're way better. There's so many, like, and mainly that's due to television and streamers, and there's just, the bad news is there's, like, a ridiculous amount of content out there and maybe too much you don't know what to watch a lot of it not so good maybe
变好了还是变坏了？嗯，你知道吗，它们变好了，而且是好太多了。有好多好多，主要这要归功于电视和流媒体，坏消息是，现在的内容多得离谱，可能都有点太多了，你都不知道该看什么，而且很多质量可能也没那么好
but that's always been the case right in our industry and now and so and I feel like I just feel like so much of the good work like the majority of the good work is being done by women I mean extraordinary work
但我们这个行业一直都是这样，对吧？现在……而且我觉得，好作品——绝大多数的好作品——现在基本上都是由女性完成的。我的意思是，非常惊艳的作品
by women and on television I agree and so it's keeping us all working And then I also feel like in terms of performers and entertainment, there has never been a bigger appreciation for women of my age. Yeah. Yeah. And that's super exciting.
都是由女性在电视上呈现的。我非常赞同，所以这让我们所有人都有活儿干。然后我还觉得，就表演和娱乐而言，从来没有哪个时期像现在这样，对我们这个年纪的女性有这么高的欣赏度。对。对。这超级令人兴奋。
And so, yeah, I've seen. But that's what I kind of mean. It's like I don't think that was the case there are 20, 30, 40 years ago, 50 years ago. And you couldn't do TV and movies. Yeah, for sure. Right, right. let alone right right that's a great point you couldn't do a commercial god forbid you should do some you you should sponsor a product or something you will never work again in the movies right like michelle
所以，是的，我看到了。但这就是我的意思。我觉得20、30、40年前，50年前可不是这样的。当时你不能拍电视剧和电影。对，确实。对，对，更不用说……对，对，说得太对了，你甚至不能拍广告，上帝保荐，你要是去代言个产品什么的，你就再也别想拍电影了，对吧，米歇尔？
like when you were making like let's say like 88 it was 88 you made dangerous liaisons or and you're making all the and you're getting nominated so you're nominated for an academy more academy award and then you call your agent you go i'm going to do this tv series they'd be like what are you out of your mind right exactly right and not even that long ago you know i remember like about Oh, maybe 10, maybe it was it 10 years ago. I was talking about, I don't know, I got offered some TV show. And I'm, well, you know, I don't know, that's kind of interesting. And they're like, no, you know, if you do TV, mm-mm.
就像你拍……比方说88年吧，那是88年你拍了《危险关系》，你拍了所有这些电影，还获得了提名，你获得了奥斯卡奖提名，然后你给经纪人打电话说：“我要去拍这个电视剧。”他们会觉得：“什么？你疯了吗？”对，一点没错。而且也没过去多久，你知道，我记得大概……哦，也许10年，是不是10年前？我在谈论，我不知道，我接到某个电视剧的邀约。然后我说，“嗯，你知道，我不知道，这挺有意思的。”他们就说：“不，你知道的，如果你去拍电视，那可不行。”
Really? It was Woody and Matthew McConaughey with True Detective, I remember, was the big, like, oh, wow, these guys are. Oh, they changed the. Yeah, I think McConaughey had just won the Oscar, like five months earlier for Dallas Byers Club maybe. And that was like, what the fuck is going on? I really feel like that was. And before that, obviously, Fincher doing House of Cards on Netflix, too, like just
真的吗？我记得伍迪和马修·麦康纳的《真探》就是那个大事件，当时大家都觉得“哦，天哪，这两个家伙……”哦，他们改变了……对，我觉得麦康纳大概就在五个月前刚刚凭《达拉斯买家俱乐部》赢了奥斯卡。当时的感觉就是：这他妈到底是怎么回事？我真的觉得那就是转折点。在这之前，显然还有芬奇在Netflix上拍《纸牌屋》，也是把流媒体
sort of launching streaming as a place where filmmakers go. So, yeah, it is really, really exciting. You don't think it was me doing the sitcom The Millers after I did Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles? Well, maybe it's, and let me tell you this, this BoJack thing that I'm hearing is coming on soon, right? Yeah, I feel so responsible. When you say tons of bad stuff, I'm like, God, I'm so responsible. Oh, trust me.
推崇为电影人去的地方。所以，是的，这真的、真的很令人兴奋。你不会以为是我演了演完《忍者神龟》之后的那个情景喜剧《米勒一家》吧？好吧，也许是吧……跟你说实话，我听说那个马上要上映的《马男波杰克》，对吧？对，我觉得我责任重大。每当你提到一堆烂摊子的时候，我就想：“天哪，我太有责任心了。”哦，相信我。
Trust me. We've all got our meeting heroes. I've done my share, bad stuff. So then what, so now you're sitting here, you're kind of, you're kind of in the catbird seat because you get to kind of pick and choose. You can do whatever you want. You can do TV and film, and you've got a new appreciation for it. And as you said, you've kind of relieved the pressure of making yourself.
相信我。我们都有过各自的黑历史。我也没少干烂事。所以然后呢……所以现在你坐在这里，你有点……你有点稳操胜券，因为你可以挑选。你想做什么都可以。你可以演电视剧和电影，而且你对它有了新的赏识。正如你所说，你算是卸下了逼疯自己的压力。
crazy. So when you look at, and, I guess now being a grandparent, now you're a grandmother. Yeah, domestic life is, and it's zenith. Is life work balance the most important? Is that the first decision? Yeah. Yeah. It is. And, you know, now, but it obviously wasn't when I committed to do all this work. I didn't know I was going to be a grandmother then. And, you know, I thought, wow, it's my time now. I can go do what I want to do. Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show.
所以当你看到……而且，我想现在你当了祖父母，你现在是奶奶了。对，家庭生活正处于它的巅峰。生活与工作的平衡是最重要的吗？这是首要决定吗？对。对。是的。而且，你知道，现在……但在我承诺接下所有这些工作的时候，它显然不是这样的。那时我不知道自己会当奶奶。而且，你知道，我当时想：“哇，现在是我的时间了。我可以去做我想做的事了。”好的，我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。
How good are you and your husband at working out this balance? Because that's a tricky part too, because you're both incredibly busy. He's very busy as well, yeah. Yeah. For my sister, for Tracy. Yeah. Please, Sean.
你和你丈夫在平衡工作和家庭这方面配合得怎么样？因为这也是个棘手的问题，你们俩都忙得不可开交。他也很忙，对。对。为了我姐姐，为了特蕾西。对。请吧，肖恩。
For my sister, who might not know your husband is David Kelly. Oh, okay. I got to say, he's been amazing. And I said to him when, again, all this work was coming up, I'm like, I'm like going to Montana and Texas for four minutes out of the year. I'm like, okay, I am not doing this unless you're with me. And don't say you're with me and then come for like a couple weeks and then go away from him. No, no, you're with me. And he's been with me. And I couldn't have, I couldn't have, because he can ride anywhere. Right, but he's doing, much more than right. He's directing, he's producing, he's doing different stuff.
为了我姐姐——她可能不知道你的丈夫是大卫·凯利。哦，好吧。我得说，他太棒了。当所有这些工作又双叒叕找上门时，我对他说：“我得去蒙大拿州和德克萨斯州待上一年中的四分钟。”我说：“好吧，除非你跟我一起去，否则我绝不接。而且别跟我说你要跟我一起去，结果只来呆个两周就跑了。不，不，你得全程陪着我。”他确实一直陪着我。我完全可以……因为他可以在任何地方码字。对，但他也在做很多别的事，比方说……他在导演，在制片，在做各种不同的事情。
Show running. He doesn't direct. Well, sort of by proxy at times, yes. Maybe, no. Well, he's pretty, he's pretty, I just worked for, I just worked with him for the, I just worked for him, with him for the first time really on Margot's Got Money Troubles. And I did, it was so fun. And I was very, I've never been really eager to work with him because,
当运作人（Showrunner）。他又不导演。嗯，某种程度上可以说是代理导演吧，是的。也许，没有。好吧，他挺……他挺……我刚刚为他工作过……我刚刚为了《玛戈有麻烦了》这部剧，真正意义上第一次和他合作。我做了，这太有趣了。我以前从来不是很渴望跟他合作，因为
I so cherish my marriage and sometimes that's the kiss of death to work together and don't be on the cover of People magazine together because you'll be divorced next year. Oh my God. So, I mean, how many times have we seen that?
我太珍视我们的婚姻了，有时候一起工作就是婚姻的催命符，千万别一起上《人物》杂志的封面，因为你们明年就得离婚。哦，天哪。所以，我的意思是，这种情况我们见过多多次了？
Right, 100 times. So it was nerve-wracking as it approached, yeah? Did you guys lay down any sort of like, listen, this is how, you could trigger me if you do this, and I know that I may trigger you if I do it. Well, he sort of set a boundary early on
对，见了一百次了。所以临近合作时还是挺让人神经紧绷的，对吧？你们有没有事先约法三章，比如：“听着，我们得这样……如果你这么做我会抓狂，而且我知道我这么做也可能会让你抓狂。”好吧，他确实在早期划定了一条界限，
when I was asking maybe too many questions. Do you really think she'd say that, David? And he's like, you know, I think that's a good question for the director. After he did that a couple times, I'm like, okay, I get it. I get it. And that was actually really good. But the truth is, this character is so well written. It's like I was born to play this part.
当时我可能问了太多问题。“大卫，你真的觉得她会这么说吗？”然后他说：“你知道，我觉得这个问题去问导演比较合适。”在他这么干了几次之后，我就想：“好吧，我懂了。我明白了。”这其实真的挺好的。但事实是，这个角色写得太好了。感觉我生来就是为了演这个角色的。
Really? She is like a real housewife of Fullerton wannabe. I grew up in Orange County. Yeah. I love, love, love her. Her name is Cheyenne, and she works at Bloomingdale's in the cosmetics department. That's brilliant. And single mom, Elle, Elle Fannie is my daughter.
真的吗？她就像一个现实版的富勒顿美国家庭主妇（Real Housewives of Fullerton）的狂热追求者。我在奥兰治县长大。对。我爱死她了、爱死她了、爱死她了。她叫夏延（Cheyenne），在布鲁明戴尔百货公司的化妆品部工作。这太绝了。而且是个单亲妈妈，艾丽，艾丽·范宁演我女儿。
I didn't get it. No, no. You can move on, John. I just found out. Anywho. So, it was, and also, gosh, how often do you get to work in Los Angeles and stay home? Yeah. I don't know where you guys live.
我没听清。不，不。约翰，你可以继续。我刚刚才知道。不管怎样。所以，而且，天哪，能在洛杉矶工作并留在家里是有多难得！对。我不知道你们住哪儿。
Will you, I don't think you're... Are you shooting? You're not shooting. You thought you'd go in Montana at shooting. But I'm not shooting right now. Okay. I'm going to Montana. When you worked with David, it was in L.A.
你会……我觉得你不在……你在拍戏吗？你没在拍戏。你以为你要去蒙大拿拍戏。但我现在没在拍戏。好吧。我要去蒙大拿。你和大卫合作的时候，是在洛杉矶吗？
It was in L.A. Right. Got it. Okay, great. So, Michelle, I, sometimes I do this and I ask people who have, as Sean said, such a wide, sort of huge breadth of work, is there a role Is there a, not a role,
是在洛杉矶。对。明白了。好的，太棒了。所以，米歇尔，我……有时我会这样问那些——正如肖恩所说——拥有如此广阔、浩瀚作品库的人：有没有这样一个角色……有没有一个……不是角色，
maybe a role, role and or film that you did of one of these great films, is there one, do you have a favorite? And it's okay. I don't. I mean, I have,
也许是某个角色、某个角色或者你拍过的某部电影，在所有这些伟大的电影里，有没有那么一部，你有一个最喜欢的？没关系，我没有。我的意思是，我有……
I have a few that are of my favorites. But it's then it's bad if I don't mention some and then the director's going to be like, oh, you didn't mention mine. Let's assume that you love them all. Let's assume you love them all, but you love one.
我有几个自己非常喜欢的。但随后如果我没提到某些作品，就会变得很糟糕，导演就会想：“噢，你没提我的作品。”我们就假设你都爱吧。我们就假设你都爱，但你最爱其中一个。
No, there's the film that I actually love the most, and then there's the performance that maybe I don't hate. Right. And then there's the experience that I have the best time on. All three, all three. All three. All three of those. Experience would be, I think, a toss-up of married to the mob,
不，有一部我其实最喜欢的电影，然后还有一个我可能不那么讨厌的表演。对。还有一段我玩得最开心的经历。三者兼顾，三者兼顾。三者全有。三者全有。经历的话，我觉得在《嫁给黑帮》和说实话《玛戈有麻烦了》之间不相上下。真的超级好玩。而我最喜欢的电影，也许是《一曲难忘》（The Fabulous Baker Boys），也许吧。对，对。太棒了。那可能也是我最喜欢的表演。哦，双料得主。也是。
and honestly, Margot's got money troubles. It was just a ton of fun. And my favorite film, maybe Baker Boys, maybe. Yeah, yeah. So good. And that might be my favorite performance as well. Oh, double did. As well.
可能是吧。太出名了。我觉得拍个续集会很棒，比如这些人后来都怎么样了？对啊。对吧？哦，是的。这主意太棒了。但我弄不动史蒂夫来拍。
Might be. So famous, too. I think that would make a great sequel, like, where are these people? Yes. Right? Oh, yes. That's a great idea. And I can't get Steve to do it.
总之。就说大卫会搞定它的。对。我能问你个问题吗？我能稍微狂热一把吗？我们很快要回希腊吗？对，《油脂》（Grease）……因为我从来没……就问几个问题，因为这辈子绝不会再发生第二次了。抱歉，米歇尔，这是我们接受粉丝提问的环节。
So, anyway. Just say David will take care of it. Yeah. Can I ask you, can I just nerd out just for a second? Are we going back to Greece soon? Yeah, Greasy just because I never got. Just like a couple questions because I'm never going to happen again in my life. Sorry, Michelle, this is where we take questions from fans.
请讲。请讲，热线观众。不，我是说，当你知道第一部那么火的时候，是什么感觉？然后你会害怕拍这个续集吗？会觉得“哦，天哪，《油脂》是一部如此宏大的作品”吗？不，拜托。我小时候觉得这可是件大事。
Go ahead. Go ahead, caller. No, like, what was it like knowing how big the first one was? And then were you like scared to do this to be in the sequel, to be like, oh my God, Greece was such a. a massive thing. No, come on. It was a big deal to me as a kid.
不，这是一个非常好的问题。当然，我当时吓坏了。对，但你在里面表现得太棒了。你真的太棒了。你知道，但是，你看，那是约翰·特拉沃尔塔、奥莉薇亚·纽顿-约翰，而且，你知道，第一部取得了巨大的成功，拥有如此狂热的粉丝群体，
No, it's a really good question. And, of course, I was terrified. Yeah, but you were so good in it. You were so good. You know, but, you know, look, it's John Travolta, Olivia Newton, John, and, you know, and it was, you know, the first one, and it was amazing and such a cult following
大获成功。然后有了我和这个小孩——麦克，他们根本不知道我们是谁，片方还打出广告说“火辣过头”。我就想：“别这么说。万一他们觉得我一点也不火辣呢？对吧？别告诉他们我很火辣。”总之。
and so successful. And then you got me and this kid, and Mack, they don't know who we are, and they're taking out ads that say too hot. And I'm like, don't say that. What if they don't think I'm hot, okay? Like, don't tell them I'm hot. Anyway.
所以当时……是的。拍的时候好玩吗？好玩，又唱又跳的。我喜欢所有这些，因为我确实喜欢跳舞，也喜欢唱歌。但我不认为……别冒汗了。我不……太明显了，我们能看到你在出汗。
So it was, it was, it was, yeah. Was it fun to make? Yeah, dancing and singing. I loved all that because I do love to dance and I love to sing. But I don't consider. Stop sweating. I don't. It's so, we could see you sweating.
我们能看到那镇定……就在镜头下方，肖恩？该死的。操。冷静点，老兄。她一提到麦克斯韦·考尔菲德（Maxwell Caulfield），这就直接爆了。顺便说一句，你知道的，
We can see the town. just below the frame, Sean? God damn it. Fuck. Cool it off, man. As soon as she mentioned Maxwell Colfield, it just exploded. By the way, you know,
我是为了你才接的，而且我是为了麦克斯韦才留下的。来几句吧，肖恩。其实主要还是为了麦克斯。说首歌名，我知道我记了好多词。开场曲。给我们来段开场曲，肖恩。串烧。不，开场曲是什么？
I wanted it for you and I stayed for Maxwell. A couple bars, Sean. It was really more about Max. Name a song, I know I have a lot of words. Opener. Give us the opener, Sean. Medley. No, what's the opener?
开场曲是什么？《School's out for...》不对，是关于学校的吗？哦，天哪，我记不得了。是雷蒙斯乐队（The Ramones）的吗？《School's out for summer》？对，不是，是这个。是这个。
What's the opening song? School's out for, no, is it school? It was about a school. Oh, God, I can't remember. The Ramones, isn't it? School's up for summer? Yeah, no, it was this. It was this.
没错。没错。摇起来。我还留着我的保龄球呢。才没有。我有。还有保龄球包。我们今晚要去保龄球馆。
That's right. That's right. Shaking it up. I still have my bowling ball. No, you don't. I do. And the bowling ball case. We're going to scone on tonight.
就是这样。我们要摇滚，我们要翻滚。我们要蹦迪，我们要打保龄。我们要去……哦，天哪。太棒了。我喜欢。耶，干得好。
That's it. We're going to rock, we're going to roll. We're going to bop, we're going to bowl. We're going to scorn, scorn, scorn, scone. Oh, God. So good. I love it. Yay, well done.
米歇尔，你每次拍完戏都会留点什么纪念品吗？对。不总是这样。不总是。有时候没有什么……你留着《一曲难忘》里的那条裙子吗？你知道吗，我没有。哦，你打算把那条裙子弄到手吗？
Michelle, do you grab a little keepsake from every single job? Yeah. Not always. Not always. Sometimes there's not... You have the dress from Baker Boys? You know, I don't. Oh, are you going to get that dress?
我留了《嫁给黑帮》里的一些戏服。我不是每次都会留，因为……剧本呢？那太占地方了。你留剧本吗？我留我的剧本。好吧，所以你有一大摞剧本堆在墙角什么的？你是把它们装订起来保存的那种吗？
I have some of the costumes from married some mom. I don't always keep them because... What about a script? They just take up room. Do you keep the script? I keep my scripts. Okay, so you've got a stack of them like on a wall somewhere? Do you have them like bound and stuff like that?
我保留了一些《老妈契合期》里的戏服。我并不总是留着它们，因为……剧本呢？它们太占地方了。你保留剧本吗？我保留我的剧本。好吧，所以你有一堆剧本，比如堆在某个地方的墙上？你是把它们装订起来还是什么的？
No, they kind of got mildewy. Yeah. And I've been trying to clean them. Do you archive stuff? No, I just... No, I don't, I just don't have time. It's all up here, right? Yeah.
不，它们有点发霉了。是的。我一直在试图清理它们。你存档东西吗？不，我只是……不，我不，我只是没时间。都在这儿，对吧？是的。
Yeah. I like that. I like that you don't. I do want to fall up before we let you go, because Jason obviously has a time crunch. Yeah, he's a hard crunch. He's got to get out, man. Because he's got to get up. And Jason, by the way, I was meaning, I was meaning to say, I'm sorry, maybe are you going to a doctor to address your gastrointestinal issues?
是的。我喜欢那样。我喜欢你没有。在我们放你走之前，我确实想最后追问一下，因为杰森显然时间紧迫。是的，他时间非常紧。他得走了，老兄。因为他得起来。顺便说一句，杰森，我本来想说，我是想说，对不起，也许你要去看医生来解决你的胃肠道问题吗？
Yeah, well, you know, the back is so stiff when I get up in the morning. It just sometimes the valve gets a little loose. I understand. Yeah. Damn it, man. Michelle understands. Okay? We're all chopped a little.
对，嗯，你知道的，早上起来的时候背部太僵硬了。有时候那个阀门就会有点松。我明白。是的。该死，老兄。米歇尔理解。好吗？我们都切除了一点。
We're all chopped, baby. We're all chopped. That's a good T-shirt. We're all chopped. Great show. Great show, by the way. Chopped. Wait, Will, you had a killer closer.
我们都被切除了，宝贝。我们都被切除了。这是件好T恤。我们都被切除了。很棒的节目。顺便说一句，很棒的节目。切除。等等，威尔，你有一个精彩的收尾。
Go ahead. No, not a killer closer, but I just want to ask you because we briefly touched upon Scarface that became this huge, of course, iconic, film, Brian DePama, you and Al Pacino.
说吧。不，不是精彩的收尾，但我只是想问你，因为我们简短地聊到了《疤面煞星》，它后来成为了一部非常巨大、当然也是标志性的电影，布莱恩·德帕尔玛，你和阿尔·帕西诺。
I didn't care for it. We have a rogue Italian critic in the back of the theater in the process of getting kicked out. Finally a question about Scarface! So, you couldn't have imagined I imagine what the cultural impact that
我不太喜欢它。我们有一个流氓意大利评论家在剧院后面正被赶出去。终于有一个关于《疤面煞星》的问题了！所以，我猜你不可能想象到
Scarface had and continues to have to this day. I mean, it's just, it's phenomenal, right? We're talking about remaking it, right? Or doing another? I think they're, I did hear something about that. Was it a television show or was it a new movie? I forget, but I did, that was a couple years ago, no? Yeah, yeah.
《疤面煞星》过去以及直到今天所产生的文化影响。我的意思是，这简直是惊人的，对吧？我们在谈论重拍它，对吧？或者再拍一部？我想他们，我确实听到过一些关于这方面的消息。是一部电视剧还是一部新电影？我忘了，但我的确，那是几年前的事了，对吧？对，对。
It comes up every once in a while. I think Universal and Anton Fuqua, maybe. I mean, I didn't have any idea it would become sort of a culture phenomenon in the way that it, and in the way that it did, too. It became this sort of cult kind of following. And so, and that was, and that was, boy, that was really intense for me. I think, I want to say the shooting went on for six months. It went over, like a couple of months.
它每隔一段时间就会被提起。我想环球影业和安东尼·福奎阿，也许吧。我的意思是，我当时根本不知道它会以那种方式，以那种方式成为一种文化现象。它变成了一种类似于邪典的追捧。所以，那，那，天哪，那对我很紧张。我想，我想说拍摄持续了六个月。超时了，大概几个月。
And I was playing a Coke addict, so I was not eating. Oh, yeah. And I kept getting skinnier and skinnier. Jason, anything? The crew were bringing me bagels and kind of, and. We're going to have to reshoot about 20 pages. Will you please eat something? Well, and then the scene at the end, you know,
我当时在扮演一个吸毒者，所以我没有吃东西。哦，是的。我变得越来越瘦。杰森，有什么要说的吗？剧组人员给我带了百吉饼之类的，而且。我们要重拍大约20页。请你吃点东西好吗？好吧，然后是最后的那个她在餐馆里的场景，你知道的，
where she's in the restaurant and, like, kind of strung out and at her worst kept getting pushed and pushed and pushed. And that was the scene where I really wanted to look my worst. Anyway. And it was also very, other than Mary Elizabeth, Master Antonio, like, we were the only women. And it was these, you know, it was like guys, you know. It was like, and gangster guys.
就像，有点神志不清，处于她最糟糕的状态，不断被逼迫、逼迫、逼迫。那就是我真的很想让自己看起来最糟糕的一场戏。不管怎样。而且除了玛丽·伊丽莎白、玛丽·安东尼奥之外，像我们是仅有的女性。全都是这些，你知道的，就像是男人们，你知道的。就像是，而且是黑帮分子。
And, you know, machismo, and they were all kind of, you know, a little bit in character all the time. Brian to Palmer, right? So, and Brian, yeah. And I was 20, I was so young. I mean, again, the last credit. I was 23. I think the last credit I had was Greece too. Wow.
而且，你知道，大男子主义，他们所有人都有点，你知道，一直都有点在角色中。布莱恩·德帕尔玛，对吧？所以，还有布莱恩，是的。我当时20岁，我太年轻了。我的意思是，再次说，上一个作品。我23岁。我想我上一个作品是《油脂2》。哇。
And I just didn't have a lot of experience under my belt. And I was terrified. Wow. Every night, I was terrified. Mm. So. A lot of that was in Florida. right
我当时并没有多少经验。我吓坏了。哇。每天晚上，我都吓坏了。嗯。所以。很大一部分是在佛罗里达拍的。对吧？
no let's see a lot of it was in L.A. Oh yeah? Most of it was in L.A. on stage and we did some
不，你看，很大一部分是在洛杉矶拍的。是吗？大部分是在洛杉矶的舞台上拍的，我们拍了一些
Florida location stuff but terrified terrified because of the newness of your career yeah? I didn't feel
佛罗里达的外景，但是吓坏了，因为你的职业生涯还很新，对吧？我觉得自己
worthy I didn't feel like I had the chops I didn't have any experience behind me I had no I had zero confidence
配不上。我觉得自己没有这个功力。我背后没有任何经验，我没有，我毫无自信。
and Al will admit this want me for the part, and I auditioned, I think, for a couple of months for it, and I knew he didn't want me going into it. Really? And one of my favorite stories is when I actually made him bleed
阿尔会承认这一点，他没有选我演这个角色，我为这个角色试镜了，我想，有几个月之久，我知道他一开始就不想要我。真的吗？我最喜欢的故事之一是，在我的试镜中，我居然真的弄出血来了。
during my screen test. How so? Wait, how so? I think, okay. Don't you want to just end there? No. No. What a story? It's a good cliffhanger.
怎么弄的？等等，怎么弄的？我想，好吧。你难道不想就此结束吗？不。不。多么棒的故事？这是一个很好的悬念。
God damn it. Okay, so I'll try to make it brief. So I'm having to audition. First of all, I come in, I do a great reading for Brian De Palma and the casting director. And I was like, it just was a good, it just happened to be good. Then they want to bring me back to meet Al.
该死。好吧，那我尽量长话短说。所以我要去试镜。首先，我进去了，为布莱恩·德帕尔玛和选角导演进行了一次出色的朗读。我觉得，这很好，碰巧就是很好。然后他们想让我回去见阿尔。
And anyway, over the course of two months, I just get worse and worse and worse because I'm just afraid. Yeah. And by the end, I'm bad. And I don't blame him. He just, he's like, I'm bad. And Brian finally comes to me and says, When, you know, you know, Dahl, it's just, it's just not going to work out.
无论如何，在两个月的时间里，我只是表现得越来越差，因为我太害怕了。是的。到了最后，我很糟糕。我不怪他。他只是，他觉得我很糟糕。布莱恩终于来对我说：“当，你知道，你知道，达尔，这，这简直行不通。”
I'm like, I know, man, I'm sorry. Because Brian really wanted me. This is what's wrong with the audition process? Is it just, the stakes get so high you can't do good. Yeah, as disappointed, well, you know that fear is the worst, is an actor's enemy. It's just as completely undermines you. So as much as disappointed as I was, I was so happy to be done with it. So, like, at least a month goes by
我说：“我知道，老兄，我很抱歉。”因为布莱恩真的很想要我。这就是试镜过程的问题所在吗？就是，赌注变得太高了，以至于你无法表现好。是的，虽然很失望，嗯，你知道恐惧是最糟糕的，是演员的敌人。它会彻底摧毁你。所以，尽管我很失望，但我很高兴能结束这一切。所以，大概过了一个月，
And I get a call, they want to bring me into screen test And I'm like, oh, so So I show up, and I don't even give shit Because I know I'm not getting this part. Sure, yeah. So when you get them. That's sexy indifference. So show up.
我接到一个电话，他们想让我去试镜。然后我想，哦，所以，所以我出现了，我甚至根本不在乎了。因为我知道我得不到这个角色。当然，是的。所以当你不在乎的时候。那是性感的冷漠。所以我就去了。
It was my best work of the film. Of course. And it's that restaurant scene where I, explode at the end, and I swipe the table of the dishes, and glasses break, the dishes break, cut. There's blood everywhere. Uh-oh. And they all run over to me to see where I've cut myself.
那是我在这部电影中表现最好的一次。当然。就是那个餐馆的场景，我在最后爆发了，我一把扫落了桌子上的盘子，杯子碎了，盘子碎了，卡。到处都是血。噢不。他们都跑来看我是不是割伤了自己。
Yeah, your hands. Well, I didn't cut me. I cut Al. Wow. No. Wow. I thought, well, there goes that part. And he's just staring at you.
是的，你的手。嗯，我没有割伤自己。我割伤了阿尔。哇。不。哇。我想，好吧，那个角色这下泡汤了。而他就那样盯着你。
Anyway, actually, I think that was the day he was like, yeah, yeah, yeah. Really? Your womb. I think, yeah, she's not bad. Charlie, yeah. And so, wait, wow, so was it, did you cut him bad and? I cut his, I think I cut him in the finger or something. Wow, wow.
不管怎样，实际上，我想那是他说“行，行，行”的日子。真的吗？你的伤口。我想，是的，她还不错。查理，是的。所以，等等，哇，那是，你把他割得很重吗，还有？我割了他的，我想我割了他的手指什么的。哇，哇。
And you went for it. You went for it. That's why, yeah, I love that. I love that. Wow. There's the lesson. Yeah. There's the lesson.
而你豁出去了。你豁出去了。这就是为什么，是的，我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。哇。这就是教训。是的。这就是教训。
You got to give a little less shit. Yeah, and if I went for it more, people wouldn't fall asleep in the front row. Exactly. Once you start breaking some glass, you know, make them say hello to your little friend. Make sure the front road's bleeding, Shawnee. Come on.
你得稍微没心没肺一点。是的，如果我更豁出去一点，人们就不会在前排睡着了。没错。一旦你开始砸碎一些玻璃，你知道的，让他们对你的小可爱问好。确保前排都在流血，肖妮。来吧。
So before you show up, you know, to do your performance, just that's your mantra. I don't give shit. I don't give a shit. I'll cut everybody. Oh, don't worry. You watch the performance. Just cut them all.
所以在你出现之前，你知道的，去进行你的表演，这就是你的座右铭。我才不管呢。我才不管呢。我要把每个人都割了。哦，别担心。你看那个表演。把他们全割了。
That's covered. Well, he's chewing. Yeah, Michelle, thank you. We have taken up, again, way too much of your time. And Jason is late for his meeting. Thanks, guys. That's all right. It's really fun.
这就对了。好吧，他在嚼东西。是的，米歇尔，谢谢你。我们再次占用了你太多时间。而且杰森开会迟到了。谢谢你们，伙计们。没关系。这真的很有趣。
Michelle, what a pleasure. Thank you so much for doing this. Huge pleasure for me, too. You're the greatest. It's such a thrill. Such an honor, truly. Thank you so much for having me. Thank you.
米歇尔，真是荣幸。非常感谢你来做客。对我来说也是巨大的荣幸。你太棒了。这真是一次刺激的体验。真是无上的荣誉。非常感谢邀请我。谢谢。
Thank you. Have a great rest of the day. Okay. Until I see you again. Bye, bye, bye. Am I supposed to do something? Do you slam your laptop, closed and disgust? Okay.
谢谢。祝你今天剩下的时间过得愉快。好的。直到我们再次相见。拜拜，拜。我是不是该做点什么？你是不是气愤地把笔记本电脑“啪”地一声合上？好吧。
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, thanks. Well, Will. Okay, okay. So I pulled it off, huh? I pulled out of pretty. Pretty, pretty nice. Yeah, no kidding. Did that cost you any money?
拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，谢谢。好吧，威尔。好吧，好吧。所以我成功了，哈？我表现得挺不错。挺，挺不错的。真的，不开玩笑。这花你钱了吗？
Like, you gotta, you gotta pay to get guests like that. I mean, she, I mean, God, how great is she? I love her. Cool. Yeah. I know, I know. I am cool. She's great, like.
比如，你得，你得付钱才能请到这样的嘉宾。我的意思是，她，我的意思是，天哪，她有多棒？我爱死她了。酷。是的。我知道，我知道。我很酷。她太棒了，真的。
Did I seem nervous? No, that is, wow, what a cool lady. I know. From the talent and the looks and everything she has, she's just a cool thing. Like so down to earth, so cool, just, it's just amazing. Got it all. And then, Jason, you did put it really well,
我看起来紧张吗？不，那是，哇，多么酷的一位女士。我知道。从才华到外表以及她拥有的所有东西，她就是个酷人。如此脚踏实地，如此酷，简直，这简直太惊人了。拥有一切。然后，杰森，你确实表达得很到位，
which is like, or was it one of you talking about... It was probably me. About how she's such a great performer. She's such a great actress, that that is the thing that shines through. Yeah, you always went for the acting, and the beauty was just sort of just a great little sidecar, as opposed to, there are some actors, male and female,
也就是，或者你们中谁在讨论……可能是我。关于她是多么出色的表演者。她是一位如此伟大的演员，这才是最闪耀的地方。是的，你总是看重演技，而美貌只是某种很棒的小配菜，与此相反的是，有些演员，无论男女，
that people do go to see like, oh, look, I want my handsome movie star, you know, and I just want to, yeah, you know, and then you leave. And it's like, you know, there was no performance stays with you, but you like the eye candy. She's just like, she's an incredible actor. Do you think that was okay that I brought up Greece 2 so much? Oh, we'll cut that out.
人们去看他们的电影是为了，“哦，看，我想要我英俊的电影明星，你知道，我只想，”是的，你知道，然后你就离开了。这就好像，你知道，没有留在你心中的表演，但你喜欢养眼的美女。她简直就是个不可思议的演员。你觉得我一直提《油脂2》没关系吧？哦，我们会把它剪掉的。
Yeah. All of them. Oh, we'll cut all, most of your stuff. By what measure do you mean okay? Like it was embarrassing. No, I know. Like, I couldn't tell you. I mean, embarrassing for you and it was awkward for her.
是的。全部。哦，我们会剪掉所有，你大部分的东西。你说的“没关系”是指什么标准？就像是太尴尬了。不，我知道。比如，我没法跟你说。我的意思是，对你来说很尴尬，对她来说很别扭。
Yeah, she was clowning you the whole time. Yeah. Yeah, that movie was so huge to me. No, we don't need more. We don't need more. No, I'm actually jealous. I never saw that one. I saw the first grease seven times in a row.
是的，她全程都在拿你开涮。是的。是的，那部电影对我来说太震撼了。不，我们不需要更多。我们不需要更多。不，我其实很嫉妒。我从来没看过那部。我连着看了七遍第一部《油脂》。
Just sitting in my theater chair with my sister. Just a couple weeks ago? Out in the valley. This was, what? We were probably 11, 12, something like that. Well, were you like sharing a bag? What was going on? The only reason we left is because the lighter ran in a butane.
就和我姐姐一起坐在影院的椅子上。就在几周前？在山谷那边。这是，什么？我们大概11、12岁，诸如此类的。好吧，你们是在共用一包零食吗？当时是什么情况？我们离开的唯一原因是因为打火机的丁烷用完了。
So we're like, well, let's get the fuck out here. This is out in the West Valley in the early 80s, and it was cheap. Stuff was cheap. So, yeah, yeah. There's no way, there's no other reason you would stay and watch it seven times in a row. the theater's cool you don't want to be sweating while you're tweaking out there in the valley
所以我们想，好吧，我们滚出这里吧。这是80年代初西山谷那边，而且很便宜。东西很便宜。所以，对，对。不可能有，绝对没有其他理由你会留下来连看七遍。影院很凉爽，你可不想在山谷那边热得满头大汗。
let John and Olivia just kind of serenade you while you just watch it again watch it again watch it again that is hilarious oh and you watched it that many times before you said oh god
让约翰和奥利维亚为你小夜曲一番，而你只需一遍又一遍地看，一遍又一遍地看，一遍又一遍地看，这太搞笑了。哦，你在说“哦天哪”之前看了那么多遍？
well I listen to the hard out yeah before I turned to my sister it's like somebody grabbed the wheel of a bus like somebody in a passenger just reached up and grabbed the wheel. My stop. What? What?
嗯，我在听到硬性结束时间之前，是的，在我转向我姐姐之前，就像有人突然抓住了公共汽车的方向盘，就像乘客中的某个人突然伸手抓住了方向盘。我的站到了。什么？什么？
Say goodbye? Yeah. Oh my God. Wait, well, Sean, if you were to say bye in a grease
说再见？是的。哦天哪。等等，威尔，肖恩，如果你要用《油脂》那种风格的歌曲说再见。
type of song. Oh, here we go. How was that? Bye, bye, bye, bye,
哦，开始了。怎么样？拜，拜，拜，拜，
bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, by,
拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，
bye, bye, everybody knew their role. Yeah. Everybody knew their role. Smart. Nice. smart less smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarf There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜，拜，每个人都知道自己的角色。是的。每个人都知道自己的角色。聪明。不错。聪明。SmartLess由贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿姆杰夫（Rob Armjarf）100%有机手工打造。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。